I'm basic you can't stop me cuz I'm cute
ha oh there is nothing I can't do and
when danger comes just know that I'm on
my way
doesn't matter where or when there's
trouble just call my name ready for some
hard-hitting questions this is serious
serious business
you wanna go first sure okay I want to
know I've actually really actually do
want to know this oh really what was
your genuine first reaction when you
heard they were gonna do a live-action
Kim Possible be honest I was excited but
I was confused because um I I was like
wait wait you guys are bringing back the
car wait what was what's happening right
it was like wow how are they gonna do
this you know like how are they gonna be
able to make the world
live-action big yeah Who am I
I'm Kim Possible I got this
[Music]
and then once I came onto set and I saw
drakken's henchman like come to life I
was like do I need to like kick their
butts now I kind of felt like even
though you know I wasn't playing him
there was a part of me that still felt a
little nervous around the henchman
that's so cool what something fans might
not know about Kim Possible that I kinda
came up with what's the sitch really
sort of that's so cool
I didn't realize that it was happening
to me in the you know in the studio hey
like what would be the way that you
would say what's up but in a modern way
what's the sitch they kind of were like
I think that works and now it's like the
catchphrase like oh that's so cool
and then they ask me yeah where do you
shop and I was like well Club Monaco and
Banana Republic Club banana so that's
maybe people didn't know about that
though for real that's super cool what
kind of research did you do did you go
back and watch every single animated
episode of Kim Possible if you did which
one was your favorite episode so you
know I was a little young for it when it
first came out but I definitely remember
watching the reruns when I was younger
and then I knew exactly what it was what
I heard about the project yeah as I got
farther in the audition process
I was started watching in more episodes
and then but actually started filming
they sent me a link with like all of
them in order and so then I watched
pretty much every single episode Wow um
I was doing my research yeah good for
you one of my favorite episodes I think
this is a lot of people's favorite
episodes it's like this little buggy
thingy like gadget buddy thingy and it
gets on Kim's neck oh yeah and she goes
neck and then it's like the controls the
emotion oh yeah yeah that was a really
fun one Wow I have to re-watch that
episode cuz I get that I can ask that
question too and I'd say that my
favorite episode is when Kim her on
switch bodies oh yes you're me are you
this is so wrong so that's your favorite
episode so that's really cool
did you know that Dakota Fanning played
baby Kim Possible what Dakota Fanning
play baby Kim Possible in in our movies
so cool my turn is so cool Hoda Fanning
and here you are I guess here I am all
are here world so you have a cameo in
this movie can you tell us anything
about it tell us everything
oh it's all the details poppy blue she's
very like gaga esque I feel like with
that hat for sure she's got this whole
this whole Gaga ask persona and she's
this larger-than-life popstar she is
sort of a throwback to when we were
doing the first couple of episodes there
was a pop star that picks up Kim in a in
a private chat yes I mean let's face it
Kim you don't I don't you don't have
your driver's license yet right so you
gotta like rely on the Marines typically
Trump you all the people she's help yeah
yeah and strangely enough I think you've
you helped poppy blue in a different way
it wasn't a way in saving her life it
was it was different different so they
have to tune in for that not only is it
that it's that throwback to some of the
original you know episodes that I could
kind of like be a part of that yeah and
feel like kind of plugged in and
connected yeah those are called like
Easter eggs yeah kind of like an easter
egg well the fans are gonna love that I
think they're gonna be so happy to see
you in this I think that day was really
fun too thanks that was fun and went
wait you would ask though so I
understand I'm coming back as a villain
that is an idea somebody write that down
right now yep that is blue that would be
so fun what was the hardest part of
filming
I'm so happy you didn't get injured by
the way I guess the most challenging
part was the whole stunt fighting aspect
has her fighting styles very martial
arts influences I learned a lot of
Taekwondo and hand-to-hand combat and
they learned how to use both staff and
me did stuff and the wires and the rigs
and
yeah that's in the air and it was all
super fun and new and exciting and so it
all sounds like a very like empowering
experience because before we started
filming so it's becoming more like Kim
Possible yeah nice process and I felt
like ready and like I could do it all
yeah but you know sometimes we'd be
learning fight sequences like the day of
or the day before and you gotta like
remember it's kinda like dance
choreography almost and and so you know
it takes a lot of tries and it it was
really fun though when I came on set I
feel like you are such a pro you really
took on Kim thank you with just like
such an amazing amazing take so I'm
really like this was a really good
interview yeah we nailed it we did know
what it is it's like we never actually
got to sit down and talk - yeah